c'est l'heure de notre second débat on
change complètement de thème c'est le
principe de cette émission on va parler
des passoires thermiques et des ratés de
notre politique de rénovation des
bâtiments la loi climat irisément oblige
les propriétaires vous le savez à faire
des travaux faute de quoi ils ne
pourront plus louer leurs appartements
qui est concerné les bailleurs sont-ils
prêts cet arpentage de Fabien reker à
Paris
c'est parti
fait le tour du propriétaire ce 3 pièces
situées dans l'est parisien acheté
375000 euros Thierry veut le mettre en
location mais il doit d'abord faire
quelques travaux de rénovation ça c'est
du simple vitrage et donc ça sera
maintenant un double vitrage c'est assez
vétuste donc on va aller sur quelque
chose de plus moderne on va mettre un
isolant donc sur le mur et ce qui va
permettre en fait d'être
beaucoup mieux isolé et ben pas perdre
de chaleur après un diagnostic
l'appartement était noté F synonyme de
faible performance énergétique depuis
cet été les bailleurs propriétaires de
logement noté F et G ne peuvent plus
augmenter le loyer c'est passoires
thermiques seront même progressivement
interdites à la location pour les
logements classés F comme celui-ci ce ne
sera le cas qu'en 2028 mais Thierry tard
a voulu prendre les devants on savait
qu'il était classé F on voulait en fait
tomber sur du D et pour se faire il
fallait
à la fois changer comme je dis les
fenêtres les volets roulants mais aussi
isolés Thierry a fait faire des devis
les travaux vont lui coûter 12000 euros
propriétaire de plusieurs appartements
ce chef d'entreprise a les moyens de les
réaliser mais ce n'est pas le cas de
tous les clients de son agent immobilier
il n'y a pas que des propriétaires
riches ou des bailleurs qui ont les
moyens il existe de jeunes investisseurs
ou des investisseurs tout court qui
ont placé leur argent et espèrent une
rentabilité
et pour lesquelles les revenus locatifs
les revenus locatifs comblent tout juste
le coût de l'emprunt et pour le moment
ses propriétaires bien non pas pu
relouer au 1er janvier leur logement il
existe pourtant des aides pour améliorer
la performance énergétique de son bien
fini le crédit d'impôt pas assez
incitatif depuis 2020 ma prime rénove
offre une prime forfaitaire versée au
moment des travaux et moduler selon les
revenus du foyer
70% des aides versées l'an dernier ont
aidé les Français à changer leur
chauffage une action vertueuse mais
insuffisante sans travaux d'isolation un
problème en particulier dans les
copropriétés peut encline à voter des
rénovations de façade et de toiture on
sanctionne entre guillemets le
copropriétaire en lui disant vous avez
un logement qui est énergivore ont été
faut savoir que c'est pas forcément le
logement mais c'est l'enveloppe c'est la
copropriété qui est énergivore et donc
on dit malgré que ce soit en définitif
la copropriété qui doit décider des
travaux c'est vous copropriétaire qui
serait sanctionné en ne pouvant plus
louer votre bien du côté des
associations de défense des locataires
on rappelle que le diagnostic de
performance énergétique existe depuis
2006 les propriétaires bailleurs ne
seraient donc pas prisonnés pourvu pour
rénover leur passoire thermique des
bailleurs en majorité aisés en France un
quart des ménages possède deux tiers du
parc de logement des particuliers
où passe les milliards de la rénovation
énergétique et thermique voilà le thème
de notre débat avec Karine Seby bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes professeur en
économie titulaire de la chair énergie
Society à l'école de management de
Grenoble spécialiste du secteur de
l'énergie et vous avez participé au
lancement de l'Observatoire européen du
bâtiment Guillaume guantard bonsoir
bienvenue à vous sénateurs écologiste de
l'Isère le groupe écologiste au Sénat
qui a lancé une commission d'enquête sur
cette notre politique effectivement de
rénovation thermique on y viendra
Christophe Demerson bonsoir bienvenue au
de vous accueillir vous êtes le
président de l'Union nationale des
propriétaires immobiliers et Mathieu
croissanto évidemment est resté à mes
côtés
Karine Seville les objectifs de de
rénovation énergétique de la loi climat
et résilience le calendrier est-ce que
ça vous semble réaliste si on essaye de
porter un regard un peu général pour
commencer ensuite en rentrant dans le
détail alors l'objectif est fixé à 2050
donc c'est vrai que on voit qu'il y a
quand même un temps qui est qui est
plutôt qui est plutôt long
dans l'état actuel de la rénovation et
du rythme et aussi des gestes qui sont
la plupart du temps mis en oeuvre
notamment au travers de ma prime rénov
qui sont des gestes par gestes et pas
des rénovations globales et profonde
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on a du mal à
s'imaginer qu'on arrivera à atteindre
ces objectifs
ceci étant le diagnostic est connu les
aides sont prévues pour évoluer
progressivement il me semble que ma
prime rénove lance des programmes d'aide
justement qui vont permettre de mieux
financer des rénovations plus
performantes avec des bouquets de
travaux donc si on part sur cette
trajectoire et qu'en accélère surtout le
rythme et qu'on passe de deux trois et
progressivement à 4% du parc rénové
chaque année
on pourra y aller mais voilà il faut
accélérer et je pense aussi je pense
aussi que la crise énergétique elle
envoie aussi un signal qui est très fort
puisque les prix de l'énergie
en Bondy et la rénovation thermique
devient très rentable et quelque chose
qui est impératif à déployer massivement
retour sur investissement comme on dit
s'accélère quoi voilà
Guillaume Gontard c'est combien de
milliards parce que par exemple ma prime
rénove pour 2023 ça a été on est passé 2
milliards 2022 à 2 milliards 500
millions en 2023 mais c'est pas il y a
beaucoup d'autres dispositifs on va
parler des bâtiments publics un peu plus
tard le thème c'est comment sont
utilisés les milliards de la rénovation
thermique aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à ça c'est justement pour cela
que vous vous demandez la Commission et
territoire au Sénat à demander et
proposer cette cette commission
d'enquête et donc qui sait d'ailleurs
réuni pour la première fois aujourd'hui
donc je suis le rapporteur c'est
justement pour ça c'est de se dire il y
a des milliards alors après on peut
regarder année après année
on pourrait toujours dire qu'il en faut
plus
utiliser il faut de l'argent ça c'est
évident je veux dire si on veut avancer
oui ça coûte faire faire la rénovation
thermique ça coûte mais c'est
indispensable par contre et c'est le
pourquoi de la de la commission
d'enquête c'est de l'argent public et
donc cette agence publique de savoir
est-ce que voilà il est bien utilisé
est-ce que voir son efficacité et voir
justement si on tient les objectifs et
ce qu'on s'aperçoit c'est que elle est
sur les 10 dernières années les
objectifs n'ont jamais été atteints à
chaque fois on avait cet objectif et
quel que soit les gouvernements parce
que là je dirais que c'est même pas la
question de on avait des objectifs de
500 000 logements rénovés on les a pas
on les a jamais atteint ça s'accumule ça
s'accumule on remet des couches aussi
successives sur ma prime rénov sur des
dispositifs qui sont différents donc on
est en train de construire un peu une
usine à gaz que plus personne ne
comprend ne comprend réellement donc je
pense qu'il y a vraiment nécessité de
regarder justement un petit peu en
profondeur l'ensemble de ces mécanismes
de voir ce qui marche parce que il y a
quand même des choses qui fonctionnent
ce qui marche pas d'évaluer aussi
d'évaluer justement de quoi elle servir
réellement cette argent public mais
c'est vrai que ça quand on voit que ma
prime rénove a 70% à financer des moyens
de chauffage quoi ça veut dire qu'on est
passé une chaudière fioul à une
chaudière gaz on peut se poser la
question de lucidité aujourd'hui donc ça
c'est vrai que sa questionne et par
contre ben voilà c'est 20 % pour de la
réelle rénovation et le nombre de
bâtiments réellement rénové BBC enfin je
veux dire là où on devrait réellement
ce consommation
si on regarde la Cour des comptes et
nous annonce 2 à 3000 logements alors on
peut après on peut discuter de ces
chiffres sur le type de qualité de
rénovation mais on voit que c'est bon
très très peu on le comprend bien on
reviendra évidemment on fera un vrai
chapitre autour de ma prime one of parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de choses à dire
Christophe Demerson passoire thermique
alors il y a une il y a des catégories
donc ils sont liées à la loi climat et
résilience avec un classement les
logements g plus sont interdits à la
location depuis le 1er janvier donc là
c'est 140000 habitations dans le parc
locatif privé 50000 habitations dans le
parc social et puis on quand on descend
il y a un calendrier qui est prévu j'ai
en 2023 géant 2025 F en 2028e en 2034
j'espère que c'est pas une colle mais
simplement la catégorie g donc ceux qui
sont les plus rapidement concernés ces
combien de c'est combien d'appartements
combien de combien de jours surtout ça
surtout ce que vous avez énoncé je
reprendrai des gens en préambule les
propos de Monsieur le Sénateur oui
effectivement tout de suite on est en
train de se diriger tout droit vers une
usagaz ou plus personne comprend rien
oui je le confirme plus personne ne
comprend rien nous on a alerté il y a
longtemps ou à l'umpi historiquement
j'allais dire historiquement on est là
pour conseiller les propriétaires et
pour les défendre donc surtout pour les
conseiller les conseillers c'est
vraiment dire quoi ça veut dire faites
des travaux c'est à dire que nous notre
discours de puissant n'existe au départ
c'est justement pour conseiller les
propriétaires à leur dire faites des
travaux donc nous ce qu'on sait c'est
que déjà chez nous nos adhérents font
des travaux nous on leur a toujours dit
fait des travaux de pourquoi pour
valoriser votre patrimoine et puis aussi
pour que vos locataires soient fidèles
qui restent chez vous qui soit bien qui
fasse des économies d'énergie on le
disait bien avant la crise énergétique
puisque valorisation du patrimoine etc
un discours c'est fait des travaux sinon
vous pourrez plus mais j'allais dire à
la limite que le vrai problème n'est pas
là et on en parlait avant de rentrer sur
votre plateau en réalité le vrai
problème c'est que on change les règles
du jeu en quoi aujourd'hui on nous parle
du nouveau du DPE le DPE Diagnostic de
Performance énergie donc c'est ce qui
permet de dire c'est un logement
mais en réalité ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que ça ce nouveau diagnostic de
performance énergétique ce nouveau DPE
les règles du jeu ont complètement
changé
et ce qu'on a vu nous c'est que les
propriétaires les plus vertueux et c'est
là que c'est grave les propriétaires les
plus vertueux avaient des notes par
exemple je vous dis je vous dirai en D
nous vous diagnostic de performance
énergétique mesdames messieurs tout le
monde se retrouve en F ou Angers alors
qu'on était en D donc après nous quand
on va voir déjà qui ont fait des travaux
on est dans des assemblées générales on
dit au genre faites des travaux investis
il faut ce que je vous ai pas répondu à
ma question le la lettre G j'ai plus
Sougé ça représente combien de ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que la lettre G
plus c'est à dire que les logements qui
sont fermés aujourd'hui à 450 kg par
mètre carré nous on le savait puisque on
avait vu les graves dysfonctionnements
du nouveau DPE on avait alerté c'est
pour ça que je veux revenir là-dessus
parce qu'en réalité c'est la genèse de
tous de toute cette usine à gaz en
réalité ce qui s'est passé c'est que
avec ce changement de règles
tout a été faussé et ce qu'on sait tout
de suite rendu compte avec le nouveau
diagnostic c'est que notamment les
petites surfaces étaient terriblement
impactées donc nous on a tout de suite
prévenu le ministère on leur dit
attention il y a des vrais problèmes je
vous rappelle quand même que dans un
premier temps le DPE était suspendu 2
mois on nous a dit oui effectivement
c'est vrai il y a des problèmes on s'est
réunions ministère on nous a dit oui il
y a des problèmes oui il y avait des
problèmes tout le monde l'a dit tous les
acteurs du bâtiment
s'il vous plaît on ferme 100000
appartements nous on dit on va pas
enfermer 100000 sur les G plus riche
on y reviendra pardon mais des réponses
un peu plus courtes et un peu moins
technique parce qu'on va perdre une
partie de nos de nos téléspectateurs je
reste quand même sur ce diagnostic
effectivement
car une cible je voudrais bien avoir
votre expertise est-ce que les nouvelles
règles sont trop compliquées pour être
appliquées c'est-à-dire pour pour déjà
classer les appartements ou les maisons
en fonction de leur efficacité thermique
on va dire ça comme ça alors le fameux
DP et bien en fait elles ont été le
nouveau DPE
je suis pas spécialiste du DPE mais je
sais que les règles elles ont été mises
en place pour essayer de simplifier et
d'harmoniser en fait les règles de
calcul parce que en fonction de l'âge de
construction des bâtiments excusez-moi
faut pas être technique mais de l'âge de
la construction du bâtiment en fait soit
c'était un DPE qui était basé sur les
consommations énergétiques des occupants
et donc là vous avez un billet parce que
le comportement de chaque ménage diffère
ou alors après une certaine date c'était
sur un diagnostic sur les performances
thermiques et je pense que l'idée aussi
c'était de d'harmoniser les modes de de
calcul et c'est vrai que on a vu qu'avec
ce nouveau DPE le nombre de passoires
thermiques j'ai pas les chiffres en tête
mais à Bondy on est à 5,2 millions de
passoire thermique
est-ce qu'on peut faire confiance aux
diagnostiqueur
c'est une très bonne question
normalement ils sont agréés
il me semble que oui moi si vous voulez
mon avis bien sûr qu'on peut faire je
suis pas l'avocat des diagnostiqueurs je
vous rassure mais on les côtoie quand
même tous les joueurs les
diagnostiqueurs c'est comme dans toutes
les corporations il y a des très bons
diagnostics il y a des bons
diagnostiqueurs les 98 % et puis il peut
y avoir effectivement quelques
diagnostics qui sont plus problématiques
mais en réalité les diagnostiqueurs font
bien leur travail mais le problème c'est
l'outil parce que on y reviendra
sûrement mais c'est le problème il est
sur l'outil on est mal parti parce qu'on
est déjà pas d'accord sur le diagnostic
de départ si je comprends bien je me dis
que vraiment il y a vraiment nécessité
de cette commission d'enquête pour faire
plus clair sur tout ça non sur les sur
les DPE et sur les diagnostiqueurs je
pense qu'effectivement il a évolué on
avait un des peu qui était très très
faible faut pas se le cacher enfin je
veux dire c'était sur du visuel et
c'était effectivement c'était trop
laxiste
alors là pour le coup c'est pas de la
faute des diagnostiqueurs c'était ce
qu'on leur demandait de faire et donc
c'est vrai qu'il y a eu un classement
qui a été qui a été réalisé je dirais un
peu au doigt
ça peut être normal qu'il soit qu'il
soit passé en en E ou en F depuis ben
voilà moi je pense que toute façon il
faut se rendre compte que un bâtiment
qui est classé un logement qui est
classé j'ai
un bâtiment qui est un salut quoi veut
dire qui est qui est enfin habité et ce
qu'il faut voir sur la question de la
rénovation thermique il y a la question
de confort de de bien vivre il y a la
question de santé il y a plusieurs
enquêtes qui ont été faits sur des
bâtiments qui sont qui sont mal chauffés
parce qu'en général c'est mal chauffé
mal ventilé question d'humidité bah
c'est un vrai impact un vrai impact sur
la santé et puis un impact économique
parce que c'est vrai que on peut parler
des loyers justement des logements mais
si la facture de chauffage c'est deux
fois trois fois le loyer on voit bien
justement et qu'à un moment donné toute
façon ça va coincer même pour les
bailleurs et sur en termes de en termes
de location donc de toute façon c'est
c'est logement ne seront plus je dirais
propres à la location donc évidemment
qu'il faut agir qu'il faut agir vite et
que c'est ind responsable alors il y a
eu cette évolution du du DPE sur lequel
voilà je pense que moi je j'attends de
voir j'ai vu l'enquête de Que Choisir
qui est effectivement et pas très en
tout cas montre effectivement les
difficultés qu'il peut y avoir avec le
même bâtiment qu'on va faire
diagnostiquer trois fois et avec des
classements qui sont totalement qui sont
totalement différents donc ça il y a
nécessité effectivement de mieux de
mieux cadrer les choses mais je dirais
qu'en fait il faut peut-être pas
s'arrêter là ce qu'on sait et c'est
qu'il faut avancer et qu'il faut
réaliser ces travaux donc voilà enfin ça
c'est comment réalise ces travaux et
surtout comment elle est réalise de
manière de manière globale parce que là
toute la problématique qu'on a et sur
l'argent public qui a été qui a été
déversé c'est ben voilà sur un logement
parce que on va avoir des démarcheurs
parce que etc on va on va changer par
exemple des fenêtres on va mettre des
fenêtres double vitrage formidable sur
un bâtiment qui est classé j'ai si on
fait pas la ventilation si on travaille
pas sur l'isolation un programme global
au contraire on va créer de la
pathologie
et donc on a besoin donc on a besoin
d'accompagnement on a besoin d'avoir une
visibilité étape par étape sur ce qu'il
faut faire et peut-être que la personne
on va lui dire c'est tes fenêtre qu'il
faut que tu changes en premier ensuite
ça sera tes combles etc mais qui dès
cette visibilité sur réellement ce qu'il
faut faire et en général la question du
chauffage c'est à dire le moyen de
chauffage c'est le dernier c'est à dire
qu'une fois qu'on a rénové totalement le
qu'on a rénové totalement le bâtiment
que justement il a besoin d'un chauffage
beaucoup plus faible là on va se poser
la question de quel type de chauffage et
là on voit qu'on fait totalement
l'inverse Christophe deerson est-ce que
parce que on parle en dypropriétaire on
imagine tout de suite quelqu'un qui a
beaucoup de beaucoup d'argent beaucoup
de moyens est-ce que tous les
propriétaires peuvent
supporter c'est c'est cette rénovation
thermique à quel point sont-ils aider
est-ce qu'il y a toujours un reste à
charge pour le propriétaire bien sûr
qu'il reste à charge nous chez nous en
moyenne les propriétaires ils ont trois
appartements à la location en moyenne
chez nous les adhérents ce que je peux
dire aussi c'est que le fait qu'on est
entre guillemets un petit peu précipiter
les choses et mille feux aux poudres
le problème cette transition on la fera
pas sur une catastrophe industrielle en
paniquant les gens ça c'est pas vrai je
n'y crois pas et je peux d'ores et déjà
vous dire que les objectifs je peux vous
le dire mais ne sont pas les trop
lentement ce que ce que disait d'accord
c'est que grosso modo les objectifs
annuels depuis
certains donc faut bien accélérer mais
ce que je veux dire aujourd'hui le vrai
problème à pression parle de ça sur le
calendrier ça va être les matériaux et
la main d'oeuvre et nous on avait alerté
je serai pas je pense pas être contredit
sur le plateau nous on avait alerté la
ministre Emmanuel Bargon là dessus je
veux dire les matériaux on peut pas
aller plus vite que la musique ça
n'existe pas je vais dire moi je suis
pas Gérard Majax
des fenêtres si vous voulez des profilés
si vous voulez toutes sortes de
matériaux c'est de la générer
effectivement le le personnel il y a
c'est un des secteurs en tension il y en
a beaucoup d'autres sur cette question
elle est fondamentale c'est vrai que je
disais on a besoin d'argent pour aller
vite mais c'est vrai que la question des
matériaux la question de toute la
filière en fait
autour de la construction de la
formation de la formation que ça soit
des architectes des équipes d'ingénierie
des entreprises derrière donc ça oui on
a mais je dirais que c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle parce que c'est tout ça
ce sont des emplois et des emplois
plutôt que si les gens sont pas formés à
l'instant T donc ça prend quelques
années je sais bien mais c'est tout ce
temps-là qu'on a perdu c'est-à-dire
qu'on a agi sur sur des primes sur
données de l'argent un petit peu comme
ça sans se poser la question globale
justement de cette de cette filière et
sur la question des matériaux moi je
pense qu'il y a quelque chose de
vraiment très intéressant à travailler
90% la rénovation actuelle c'est fait
avec des matériaux issus de la
pétrochimie c'est à dire fenêtre PVC
polystyrène etc je pense qu'on est en
train de créer un problème dans les
années les années à venir sur le
recyclage de ces matériaux la
réutilisation même les problèmes
sanitaires sur certains matériaux là on
a une chance de se dire comment on
produit mieux des matériaux justement
beaucoup plus local sur la question des
matériaux bio sourcés alors on a des
choses qui sont en train ou le soir
qui permet d'avoir moins d'impact aussi
sur le sur le recyclage de ces matériaux
là et évidemment qu'il faut avancer
là-dessus donc ça fait partie aussi de
du travail que l'on va mener pour pour
montrer qu'on a besoin aussi en
parallèle d'avancer sur ces feuilles la
question volontairement provocatrice et
j'aurais pu commencer par là est-ce que
ça sert vraiment à quelque chose car il
s'est dit ça parce que en Allemagne au
Royaume-Uni il y a des études qui nous
disent que la baisse de consommation
après rénovation énergétique elle est
faible et surtout elle dure pas
longtemps alors merci effectivement de
revenir sur ce point là parce que c'est
dommage que les médias en fait titres de
cette manière plutôt mensongère parce
que quand on lit ces titres on a
l'impression que en fait les gains
d'efficacité énergétique au bout de deux
ans ont disparu et en fait parce que les
gens
reprennent leur confort quoi c'est ça
c'est ce qui a été dit c'est que il y a
des effets pervers qui sont bien connus
et notamment les faits rebonds
c'est qu'au bout de se remet à chauffer
à ce moment là ça sert plus à grand
chose c'est peut-être un manque de
pédagogie auprès des des locataires ou
des propriétaires mais je pense que
l'étude britannique serait refaite
aujourd'hui en pleine crise énergétique
je pense qu'avec la sobriété qui est on
va dire qui a été imposé on aurait
peut-être pas cet effet l'argument mais
les feux rebond en fait aussi il faut
revoir et c'est là où je reprends un
petit peu l'argument de de Monsieur
Gontard c'est que la plupart des
passoires thermiques elles sont occupées
par des logements qui sont précarité
énergétique qui sont dans des logements
insalubre donc c'est vrai que avant de
la mise en place de cette rénovation
thermique c'est c'est ménages se
chauffer difficilement à 17 degrés il
faut savoir qu'au Royaume-Uni il y a
beaucoup de ménages qui sont en
précarité énergétique donc c'est une
cible vraiment qui est à ciblée et une
fois que la rénovation en fait elle est
elle est elle est faite c'est vrai que
les gens ils vont améliorer leur confort
ils vont trouver que c'est plus facile
de se de se loger à 19 degrés et je
trouve que c'est
il y a des gains de santé publique c'est
ce que vous nous dites ce qu'il faut
intégrer au bilan d'accord et après il y
a aussi une particularité britannique
c'est qu'on retrouve aussi ailleurs en
Allemagne c'est que c'est un biais
comportemental c'est qu'il y a beaucoup
de ménages aussi qui vont
effectuer ces travaux de rénovation lors
de l'extension de leur maison de leur
logement et apparemment au Royaume-Uni
sont très friands des vérandas on peut
peut-être les comprendre et forcément
vous agrandissez la taille de vos
logements et donc vous agrandissez aussi
la rénovation la consommation
énergétique mais oui il faut pas prendre
uniquement que le coût de la rénovation
mais il faut prendre aussi tous les
gains les bénéfices tels que le confort
l'amélioration de la santé
l'amélioration aussi de la valeur
foncière la valeur verte des biens et je
trouve que c'est dommage de tuer le
gisement en voilà en ayant ces messages
qui sont plutôt provocateurs et je vous
l'accorde et vous aurez eu la
possibilité de détailler les arguments
va ouvrir un chapitre un peu plus
politique parce que ce thème et ses
enjeux ils sont évidemment très
politiques Mathieu le président de la
République qui veut reprendre la main
sur la planification écologique oui une
réunit demain conseil de la
planification écologique pour fixer la
feuille de route gouvernementale sur ce
terrain alors officiellement on le sait
c'était plutôt à sa première ministre de
le faire puisque c'est la mission
prioritaire qui lui avait été confiée
mais avec les retraites à la sans doute
d'autres chats à fouetter officiellement
on le sait aussi ça aurait pu être façon
ministre de la transition écologique de
le faire de prendre le relais mais ce
dernier a bien quand même bien de la
peine à exister au-delà de sur son
papier à lettre du ministère et puis il
faut le dire enfin Emmanuel Macron sur
ce sujet a lui aussi des choses à se
faire pardonner et notamment cette
petite phrase pendant tes au détour de
ses vieux aux Français sur un mode
interrogatif qui aurait pu prédire la
crise climatique aux effets
spectaculaires l'été dernier petite
phrase qui lui a valu évidemment bien
des sarcasmes et des critiques oui y
compris dans son propre camp alors il
faut dire que pour un président qui
était déjà accusé par l'opposition et
beaucoup une association d'être celui de
l'inaction climatique c'est ce qu'on
appelle ce tirer une balle dans le pied
le bad buzz a été tel qui Emmanuel
Macron a dû se fendre d'une vidéo
d'explication sur les réseaux sociaux un
média qu'il affectionne beaucoup depuis
l'automne dernier pour parler
environnement aux Français j'ai été mal
compris a-t-il tenté de se justifier en
reprochant à ses adversaires de le
caricaturer avant de remettre une couche
en assurant que la dégradation
climatique avait été beaucoup plus vite
que prévu jusqu'à deux nouveaux étaient
démenti par des experts bref en quelques
mois le volontarisme écologique affiché
par le chef de l'État depuis sa
réélection afepshit et du coup ça fait
passer à la trappe la Loi sur le
développement des énergies renouvelables
par exemple que sa ministre de la
transition énergétique a gagné sur une
hachée était pourtant parvenu à faire
adopter sans esclandre ni 49-3 avec une
forme de discussion à la fois au Sénat
et à l'Assemblée et puis elle attrape
aussi les autres initiatives
présidentielles comme l'annonce de futur
RER dans dimitropole ou encore le deal
passé avec les industries les plus
polluants de France pour les inciter à
décarboner alors demain pas de risque de
déra en tout cas puisque la réunion se
tiendra hors caméra avec quel objectif
la communication il s'agit quand même de
faire un point d'étape secteur par
secteur sur la trajectoire des missions
de gaz à effet de serre on sait que la
stratégie française on le rappelle
repositionne une réduction de 40 % mais
l'Europe a fixé comme objectif 55 %.
donc du coup la France doit à la fois
refaire son retard et avancer fixer un
calendrier une méthode pour se mettre en
face sur sur les bons rails c'est quand
même un très très gros chantier qui à
mon avis dépassera le cadre de cette
seule réunion de demain évidemment
Guillaume Gontard la planification
écologique qui était promise elle se
elle se fait attendre peut-être qu'il
faut expliquer pourquoi c'est aussi
important d'avoir ce que vous disiez là
on est sur le logement et il faut une
finalement une action globale mais c'est
c'est vrai aussi d'une planification
écologique pourquoi c'est important de
planifier l'action bah déjà c'est
évident que c'est important après
heureux que le Président de la
République reprennent ces termes parce
qu'il a mis du temps quand même à
comprendre que justement c'était
important c'était important de planifier
après moi ce qui me désole c'est qu'on
est encore avec ces types de réunions
alors on a eu on a tous les noms de on
se réunit beaucoup on réfléchit beaucoup
c'est très bien mais je pense que le
temps de la réflexion il devrait être un
petit peu derrière nous c'est à dire que
maintenant les actions ça a été dit
l'Europe c'est enfin les objectifs
européens c'est 55 % de baisse de gaz à
effet de serre d'ici 2030 2030 c'est
dans 7 ans et je suis on regarde la
trajectoire qu'on est en train de
prendre c'est évident qu'on les
atteindra pas parce qu'on pense
dans les clous de notre propre de ce
qu'on sait même même fixé je rappelle
que l'avoconventions citoyenne c'est pas
moi pareil qu'il est qu'il a inventé
c'est le président de la République et
là pour le coup j'ai trouvé que c'était
plutôt une bonne idée quand il l'a fait
ce qu'il avait demandé aux citoyens et
aux citoyennes c'était de dire justement
dites moi comment je peux arriver à
baisser de 40% d'ici 2030
bah les citoyens citoyens ils ont donné
ils ont donné des éléments donc je veux
dire on les trajectoire ce qu'on doit
mettre mettre en oeuvre que ça soit sur
la question des transports que ça soit
ils sont sur la rénovation thermique sur
les questions de l'alimentation sur
l'agriculture etc on sait ce qu'il faut
faire je parlerai pas des rapports du
GIEC qui nous dit exactement aussi ce
qu'il faut faire sur le développement
des énergies renouvelables oui on a voté
on a voté un texte d'ailleurs bon il y a
eu la commission mix paritaire
juste aujourd'hui
on voit bien que on est quand même très
très loin du compte on vote un texte
c'est je dirais c'est mignon on a on a
un peu simplifié des choses on va
pouvoir un petit peu développer il y a
une certaine volonté mais il y a pas de
budget enfin je veux dire on a on a pas
du tout parlé de financement de ces
énergies de ces énergies renouvelables
pardon on n'a pas parlé encore une fois
de filière c'est quand même assez
hallucinant c'est-à-dire qu'on va mettre
des milliards et ça c'est plutôt
intéressant sur par exemple le
photovoltaïque photovoltaïque en France
on a du silicium on a des entreprises
qui étaient en capacité de faire des
panneaux photovoltaïques bah non on ne
s'occupe pas de cette filière là et on
va c'est 40 milliards directement en
Chine avec avec l'importation je pense
que là oui il y a pour le coup un vrai
besoin de planification
globale avec des marques chinoises qui
commencent à arriver sur le territoire
mais ça c'est un autre débat qu'on fera
sûrement dans cette émission je reviens
à la question du logement qui qui fait
aussi l'objet de bataille politique de
batailles internes au sein de la
majorité présidentielle dans une
interview au magazine Le Point l'ancien
Premier ministre Édouard Philippe
qualifie de folie c'est le terme qu'il
emploie cette interdiction de la
location des passoires thermiques il
affirme que les premières victimes de
cette mesure seront les locataires les
plus fragiles qui auront beaucoup de mal
à trouver un logement dans un marché
locatif locatif pardon qui va s'assécher
est-ce que ce risque est réel Christophe
Demers absolument pourquoi absolument le
risque est réel je vais vous dire
pourquoi parce que nous nous on est dans
le conseil et nous et de la première
chose qu'on dit c'est au bailleur
respecter la loi donc pour nous il est
hors question de dire un bailleur
relouer l'appartement alors qu'il est
rangé plus nous on dit non déjà parce
que il y a les risques objectifs et puis
après nous on en fait dans les clous
c'est pour ça que je reviens et je vais
dire ça ça se planifie c'est à l'avance
c'est de l'industrie lourde on peut pas
donc le bailleur aujourd'hui il est dans
une impasse on prenait l'exemple sur les
petites surfaces ce qu'on sait
aujourd'hui et nous on avait prévenu on
sait les mots courts les toutes petites
surfaces et les petites surfaces les
étudiants ils vont en stage on nous
avait dit partiront pas oui on sait très
bien que les étudiants ils partent en
stage ils partent en stage quand par
exemple bah non elle fin d'année donc ça
veut dire que aujourd'hui c'est des
petits appartements ils sont fermés on
les relou plus nous on va pas dire les
louer donc là je peux déjà parler 200000
appartements qui sont qui sont
impossibles à louer léger plus depuis
vous nous disiez c'est des appartements
les laisser sur le marché
ça sera déjà ça sera pas 200000 je vous
dis tout de suite nous on a dit ça sera
400 minimum mais tous les appartements
que vous voyez sur les boulevards et par
définition les appartements d'étudiants
ils sont au quel rythme à ce moment-là
monsieur parce que j'entends l'argument
attention risque d'assèchement du marché
locatif mais il faut bien les remplacer
quelque chose de Global parce que si on
dit en même temps si on s'attaque les
les les plus je veux dire il y a pas les
matériaux donc il faut c'est comme dans
une guerre il faut choisir
c'est que mettez-vous à la place du
bailleur par exemple vous êtes dans une
lettre vous êtes un F ou il fallait
prioriser il fallait prioriser il
fallait dire jour on était d'accord pour
déjà assécher finir les travaux
complètement éradiquer léger plus et
léger on aurait déjà fait ça c'était
pour nous c'était une victoire parce que
c'était vraiment l'urgence
on le dit et je le redis sur les
bâtiments j'ai j'ai plus c'est des
bâtiments qui sont insalubre enfin je
veux dire dans lequel on peut pas vivre
correctement avec avec des coups de
chauffage avec un confort qui n'est pas
enfin voilà donc est-ce qu'on accepte
moi j'entends Édouard Philippe il nous
dit ok donc on préfère laisser des gens
dans des conditions assez libre moi ça
me satisfait pas donc qu'est-ce qu'on
fait et moi je pense que quand même il y
a des objectifs qui date pas d'hier non
plus parce que à un moment donné
pourquoi c'est rentré dans la loi
pourquoi on a mis justement je suis pas
pourquoi on a mis des dates c'est aussi
parce que ça attardé et on nous a pas
laissé assez le temps pour changer
l'accompagnement en changeant les règles
du jeu il y a de l'argent quand même qui
est mis qui est mis et qui accompagne
donc je pense mais c'est un petit peu
pareil que quand vous avez une voiture
si elle n'a plus son contrôle technique
elle peut plus rouler ben on roule plus
avec parce que c'est dangereux le
sénateur c'est de la même manière
le sujet il est pas là le sujet il est
tout simplement que les règles du jeu
elles ont été changées en marche et ce
qu'on sait par exemple aujourd'hui dans
les petits surfaces j'insiste sur les
petites surfaces mais c'est parce que ça
sera vraiment ce qui va exploser je veux
dire en termes sociétales par exemple on
sait qu'un chauffe-eau le le chauffage
de l'eau c'est un vrai enjeu donc le
chauffage de l'eau un chauffe-eau que
vous ayez une petite surface ça va
beaucoup plus impacter que si vous êtes
dans 100 m², mais en réalité je veux
dire l'étudiant il prendra la salle où
je la même manière on n'a pas entendu
Karine c'est bis sur sur cet aspect je
reprends les termes de d'Édouard
Philippe risque d'assèchement locatif
notamment pour finalement les français
qui sont en situation les plus précaires
alors c'est vrai que l'interdiction elle
envoie un message fort et il va y avoir
plein de d'appartements qui ne seront
plus et de maison qui ne seront plus sur
le sur le sur le sur le marché après un
argument c'est que c'est vrai que la
France a tapé fort et même cette mesure
qui n'est pas nouvelle et qui est
annoncée enfin moi je sais que depuis
que je suis dans des groupes de travail
où j'entends des propositions de mesure
ça fait presque 10 ans qu'on en entend
parler de cette interdiction de location
vous êtes en train de nous dire que les
propriétaires ont eu le temps disons que
c'était sur c'était proposé depuis
longtemps ça a été peut-être mis en
oeuvre d'une manière peut-être brutale
et quand on regarde et on fait un
benchmark au niveau des pays européens
c'est vrai que la France est précurseur
sur ce type d'interdiction d'ailleurs ça
peut choquer certains pays il les
Pays-Bas qui ont un type d'interdiction
mais pour les bureaux et au Royaume-Uni
il me semble qu'il y a aussi une
interdiction une loi qui est similaire
mais elle a été par exemple retoquée au
niveau de la directive alors je l'ai en
anglais la directive de la performance
énergétique des bâtiments donc on voit
bien que ça peut poser souci mais dans
l'autre côté dans notre côté dans notre
côté il s'agit de bâtiments qui sont
insalubles et puis on puisse qu'on parle
des propriétaires aujourd'hui ma prime
rénove alors ce sont peut-être pas des
propriétaires bailleurs mais les
propriétaires occupants m'imprime
rénovent aujourd'hui elle concerne 80%
des ménages français qui sont modestes
voire très modestes et la classe moyenne
et on voit que petit à petit alors il y
a une certaine inertie dans le
déploiement des des mesures mais on va
dans le bon sens puisque l'idée c'était
de massifier alors c'est sûr que ce sont
des rénovations qui sont gestes par
gestes on répond pas aux enjeux la
question que vous m'avez posée au départ
ça c'est pas en faisant geste par geste
par étape comme ça qu'on arrivera à des
rénovations globales mais il faut
prendre le temps parce que la filière
n'est pas aussi des artisans ne sont pas
prêts non plus pour faire de la
rénovation globale mais ma prime rénove
intègre petit à petit me semble-t-il des
mesures sur le modèle allemand qui est
pionnier en Europe sur les systèmes de
subventions qui proposent des aides qui
sont proportionnelles en fait aux
économies d'énergie qui seront qui
seront
enfin voilà qui sera escomptés
c'est-à-dire que plus votre rénovation
elle est ambitieuse et plus vous aurez
de subventions aujourd'hui ma prime
rénov ne le fait pas vraiment et ça
c'est une proposition qui va venir avec
mon accompagnateur Réno avec etc
vous vouliez intervenir ensuite on va
parler des bâtiments publics absolument
je vais lui interdire pourquoi parce
qu'après malgré tout dans le logement ce
qui prime c'est le principe de réalité
et c'est le temps long les objectifs
tout le monde les partage tout le monde
les partage mais après la question
simple je vais vous prendre un seul
exemple j'étais avec le sénateur Longeau
juste avant de venir je lui ai parlé une
pénurie qui va vous parler tout de suite
parce que là c'est un peu abstrait les
tuiles moi j'étais j'ai traversé j'ai
passé du Puy-de-Dôme je suis passé par
Vichy et la Saône-et-Loire pendant plus
de 100 km je voyais toutes les maisons
je dis bien là on est au mois en
décembre donc il y a 15 jours toutes les
maisons vachées je me suis arrêté j'ai
dit mais qu'est-ce qui se passe maison
9 juin le 9 juin il y a eu la grêle on
est on est moi c'était fin décembre on
est le 15 janvier tous les objectifs
tout ce que vous voulez ok d'accord il y
a pas de tuile on les fabrique commun
j'écoutais les propos de notre sénateur
bien sûr le bio sourcé les matériaux
chez nous les tuiles et c'est pas loin
la soie network les tuiles elles sont
fabriquées à côté il y a pas de tuiles
tuile aujourd'hui c'est du gaz et de la
terre ça coûte plus cher à fabriquer une
tuile après on peut me dire on peut tout
expliquer et par nos interrompre et je
voudrais qu'on parle des bâtiments
publics grâce à Mathias qui peut revenir
sur ce plateau rebonsoir Mathias bonsoir
bienvenue à vous donc on va parler de la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments
publics et oui c'est une œuvre
pharaonique Thomas accrochez-vous à
votre siège il y aurait 400 millions de
mètres carrés à rénover prix total du
chantier du siècle ce sont les mots de
Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique 500 milliards
d'euros ni plus ni moins que le budget
de l'État pour un an il va donc falloir
étaler ses projets sur les années à
venir et en même temps accélérer car
depuis 2018 l'état n'y a consacré que
3,8 milliard d'euros cela dit tout d'un
combat directement à sa charge en
réalité sur les 400 millions de mètres
carrés environ un quart relève de sa
compétence le reste étant des bâtiments
des collectivités locales alors on parle
de quel type de bâtiment et bien
essentiellement des écoles une bonne
partie des 60 000 établissements
scolaires d'ailleurs des bâtiments
administratifs des préfectures des
bibliothèques même le palais de l'Élysée
dont la toiture a pourtant été refait
récemment aurait son côté passoire
thermique d'après des membres du
gouvernement autant de chantiers avec
plusieurs objectifs objectifs un la
transition écologique évidemment et
l'objectif de notre réalité carbone à
horizon 2050 2 et ce n'est pas à
négliger un bâtiment mieux isolé
consomme moins écoute donc moins cher
quels sont les moyens mis en place
notamment pour les collectivités locales
alors il y a le budget habituel à louer
aux collectivités dont 5,5 milliards ont
été consacrés à cet ouvrage 2,7
milliards du plan de relance le
ministère de la transition écologique a
également annoncé récemment un fond vert
de 2 milliards mais le compte au final
n'y est pas d'où la proposition défendue
par la députée Renaissance Aurore berger
visant à ouvrir le tiers financement
pour les rénovations énergétique le
principe un tiers publics ou privé
apporte des fonds qui manqueraient au
projet permettant ainsi d'accélérer le
déclenchement des travaux en
contrepartie ce tiers se remboursera
avec des intérêts sur les économies
réalisées grâce à la rénovation le texte
a été voté en première lecture à
l'Assemblée nationale le 19 janvier
dernier il sera présenté au Sénat le 16
février merci Mathias Guillaume Gontard
faudrait peut-être déjà que l'État les
collectivités locales balaye de devant
leur porte est-ce que le retard pris
pour les bâtiments publics et au même
niveau que pour le privé ou est-ce que
c'est encore pire je pense que on doit
être au même niveau voir voir pire alors
après avec des difficultés aussi qui
peuvent être différentes vous avez parlé
de l'Elysée mais en tout cas sur la
question de de bâtiment
historique etc sur lequel il peut y
avoir des difficultés effectivement vers
les techniques en tout cas sur la
question de la rénovation thermique mais
c'est sûr qu'il y a eu un retard
considérable qui a été pris que ce soit
sur je dirais en charge de l'État mais
sur l'ensemble des collectivités mais ça
encore une fois on parlait de
panification de de choix je dirais et de
motivation en fait pour les pour les
collectivités je pense que ça passe ça
passe par des priorations et notamment
en termes d'aide et subventions alors
évidemment il faut de l'argent ça c'est
c'est indéniable encore une fois et
c'est sûr qu'on voit bien que ce qui a
été mis au oppo jusqu'à présent et loin
d'être suffisant mais il y a aussi sur
l'orientation de cet argent et c'est
vrai que dans les collectivités je vois
notamment à travers à travers certaines
régions si on met pas de
conditionnalités justement sur les aides
c'est à dire qu'à un moment donné
les aides qui peuvent être apportées à
une commune si on priorise pas en disant
ben avant peut-être de faire un projet
de faire un nouvel équipement il va
peut-être falloir isoler travailler sur
votre équipement parce que ça va faire
baisser le coup de le coup de fou dire
qu'il y a des milliards qui ont été mal
utilisés depuis des années il va falloir
mais en tout cas de prioriser on est
bien enfin on est bien dans cette dans
cette question là on a un peu une
urgence mais une urgence qui se retrouve
je veux dire les collectivités
aujourd'hui qui ont fait cet effort
d'isolation qui ont travaillé sur leur
économie d'énergie à tous les niveaux
bah aujourd'hui sont forcément moins
impactés par l'augmentation des des prix
des prix d'énergie donc on y a vraiment
intérêt donc c'est vraiment de prioriser
là-dessus de se poser aussi les bonnes
questions parce que même si le parc de
de bâtiment et de et de logement
existants et le plus important mais il
faut aussi réfléchir au bâtiment et aux
équipements qu'on construit aujourd'hui
moi j'ai encore vu des projets notamment
par exemple de piscine
où je me dis c'est pas possible on va
construire des équipements sans se poser
la question du chauffage où on a encore
avec des types de de chauffage soit
électrique sans sans avoir de réflexion
de réflexion globale peu de peu
d'isolation en tout cas le minimum
réglementaire alors qu'on sait que c'est
des équipements qui sont faits pour
durer un certain temps et qui vont avoir
un impact et on le sait bien la
difficulté des collectivités c'est sur
leur budgets de fonctionnement et donc
c'est là où on doit réellement
travailler et là c'est sûr qu'on est
très très loin du compte car il s'est
mis je rappelle vous avez participé à
l'Observatoire européen du bâtiment vous
disiez que la France était peut-être un
peu pionnier sur les mesures coercitives
on va dire avec l'interdiction de la
location des passeports thermiques
est-ce que à l'inverse si on compare
notre parc public je sais pas si vous
avez la réponse je veux pas vous vous
coller mais à celui d'autres pays
européens est-ce qu'il y a des efforts
de rénovation qui ont été fait plus tôt
par d'autres voilà moi j'aurais juste
réagir à ce qui a été présenté par par
votre collègue en fait ça s'appelle le
contrat de performance énergétique c'est
connu pareil comme les ferrerobans c'est
vieux comme le monde et c'est une mesure
qui a été mise en place en fait en
Allemagne depuis presque 15 ans et
l'avantage en fait si vous voulez c'est
que ça ça pique bien au niveau des
bâtiments publics parce que vous avez
des économies d'échelle et plus
difficilement justement sur
le parc résidentiel ou là c'est plus
petit et vous avez des économies
d'énergie qui sont pas forcément
garanties à cause de l'effet rebonds et
là en fait sur les bâtiments publics on
peut mieux gérer avec des management de
d'énergie etc et les ce sont les
économies d'énergie en fait qui vont
payer petit à petit au fil de l'eau
l'investissement initial donc
cet exemple est bon ensuite pour pour
mettre en avant peut-être une innovation
une mesure qui est plutôt innovante et
mise en avant en France c'est
aujourd'hui ça s'appelle France Renov
mais par exemple on est en France je
crois le seul guichet unique au niveau
national qui garantit si vous voulez un
service public qui garantit un conseil
neutre de qualité et indépendant et qui
va être personnalisé en fonction des
besoins avec un relais local je crois
qu'on a 550 agences dans les territoires
et ça quelque chose qui qui est
développé premièrement développé en
France en Europe
ensuite l'Allemagne et est un exemple je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure sur le programme
de de financement avec cette
proportionnalité des aides accordées en
fonction des économies d'énergie il
faudrait cumuler en fait France enfin ma
prime rénov puisqu'on a des aides qui
sont proportionnelles aujourd'hui aux
revenus avec des aides qui sont de plus
en plus qui sont progressives en
fonction des fonctions des économies
réalisées merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat c'est la
fin de ce numéro de sciences publiques
je vous dis à demain sur Public Sénat et
puis notez votre prochain rendez-vous
politique dans la matinale Oriane
Mancini reçoit le prénom des sénateur LR
Bruno Retailleau belle soirée à toutes
et à tous
[Musique]